today on the matt walsh show the media
and blm activists want you to forget
that
reasonable doubt is the standard in the
derek chauvin trial and
in every other trial all that matters is
whether there is reasonable doubt
about chauvin's role in floyd's death if
there is he should walk
so is there we'll talk about that today
also five headlines including the police
chief in dc justifying his decision to
be
lenient on the two girls who murdered
muhammad anwar during that carjacking
how would his reasoning apply to the
chauvin case and also scientists look to
extend human life by harvesting
blood from the young yes they're really
doing that plus
white liberals are asked about their
stance on voter id and their responses
are incredibly though expectedly racist
and finally in our daily cancellation
another member of the view is on the
chopping block i'll explain why that and
much more
today on the matt wall show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
now a quick word from policy genius no
before policy genius
existed there was a time before that and
if you wanted to get affordable life
insurance maybe some people remember
this it was a it could be a
difficult complicated confusing process
but that's not the case anymore you can
protect your loved ones by getting life
insurance with policy genius and it's
very easy to do so you are
you are without excuse policy genius can
help you compare top insurers in one
place and save 50
or more on life insurance once you find
your best option the policy genius team
will set up your new policy for you and
answer any questions you have along the
way
and you can feel good knowing that your
family has financial protection
getting started is very easy here's all
you gotta do first head to
policygenius.com the minutes you can
work out how much coverage you need and
compare quotes to find your best
price since their license agents work
for you not the insurance companies
there's zero hassle and they're just
gonna find you the best deal it's as
simple as that if you hit any speed
bumps during the application process
policy genius
will take care of everything that kind
of service has earned policy genius
a five-star rating across thousands of
reviews on trustpilot
and google if you wanna see why people
love it so much then go to policy genius
they can promise
that you won't leave their website
feeling like a fool you could save 50
or more by comparing life insurance
quotes and feel good knowing that if
something happens your loved ones are
taken care of
so go to policygenius.com to get started
policy genius when it comes to insurance
it's nice to get it right
as the trial of derek shoven continues
nearly two weeks into the proceedings
it's as clear as ever that the trial of
derek chauvin doesn't really matter to
the people who
demanded that he'd be put on trial from
the very moment that they saw the
infamous video last may
for the media blm the left generally the
trial
is but a formality a bit of a symbolic
theater
they arrived at their conclusion when
they watched the video probably even
before they watched it in many cases
and the only point of the trial is to
affirm
that conclusion it's not to prove
anything proof is irrelevant truth is
irrelevant
for this crowd the truth is whatever
they feel and the job of the rest of the
world is to validate those feelings
that's how they approach all of life and
that certainly includes the court system
and it's why we now are living under a
terrorist threat
from these same people we all know that
they'll riot
and kill and burn and destroy if they
don't get their way every person in the
country knows this
and we're meant to accept it we're meant
to simply cope with the fact that we now
live in a country where
if one side of the ideological divide is
ever made very mad about something
they'll kill people and burn down
buildings and be allowed to do it given
space to do it to use the former
baltimore mayor's phrase give them space
to destroy
she said we're also supposed to tolerate
and accept that the left is
using terrorist threats to influence the
outcome of a murder trial
blm activists and others have not been
veiled or subtle
about this at all if they don't get
their way
they'll destroy your neighborhood maybe
kill you in the process
that's the threat and we know they'll
really do it because they've already
done it many times
what this means is that the well has
already been poisoned
you know if the jury finds chauvin
guilty it could very
easily be because they don't want to
cause rioting
and they know that an acquittal would
would bring that
also they don't want they don't want to
worry about being doxed and their lives
permanently ruined and endangered
because of it because we know that's
also going to happen
now maybe if they come back with a
guilty verdict it'll be because that's
how they honestly read and interpreted
the facts of the case
that could also be it but we'll never be
able to know that
we'll never know to what extent the
terrorist threats
influence the outcome of the trial if
they come back with a guilty verdict
ironically then the only outcome the
only verdict we can trust
is an acquittal we know if they find
guilty it would
very well it could very well be because
of terrorist threats
not necessarily but it that could be the
reason or part of the reason
if they acquit it will be in spite of
the terrorist threats they'll be finding
that way in spite of the fact
that they risk their own lives and doing
so there couldn't be any
feasible motivation to come to that
decision other than
that it's the correct decision in their
view so that's what we're faced with
this is what the left has done to this
country in one of the highest profile
murder cases in modern american history
perhaps the most type the highest
profile of all
the only verdict that we can be sure was
arrived at honestly and based on the
facts of the case
is the very verdict that would cause our
cities to burn
it's the double-edged sword of all
double-edged swords the consequence of
living in a country where millions of
people
have just thrown truth out the window
and morality out the window
but for those of us who still care about
the truth and who are following this
case and actually evaluating the
evidence on its own merits
whatever small portion of people fall
into that category for those people
i think it's important to emphasize one
important and um and
and simple point this is a point that
has been totally lost in the media
coverage and even many of the seemingly
honest
people i've talked to who really want to
know the truth in this case and
really want true justice to be done one
way or another
seem to have forgotten or lost sight of
this
and and the point is this reasonable
doubt
okay that's the standard i'm not a
lawyer not a legal expert or a legal
scholar but i know that much
because that's simple that's basic level
derek chovin's
lawyer doesn't need to prove
that chauvin is innocent all he needs to
do is demonstrate that there is
reasonable doubt about his guilt all he
has to establish is that the prosecution
has not fully established its own case
if you're sitting on the jury and you
say to yourself when all is said and
done well
i think he really might have killed
floyd but it's also plausible that he
didn't
that should be a vote to acquit i mean
we don't convict people or we aren't
supposed to convict people
in this country based on mites and
maybes
ah they maybe i think he probably did
but we'll convict him that's not the way
it's supposed to work
we convict based on certainty beyond all
reasonable doubt
now the prosecution is still making its
case the defense hasn't even really
begun to present its own case but so far
based on what we what we based on what
we knew going into the trial
and what has come out during the trial
there is
so far a whole heap of reasonable doubt
you know the prosecution says that
chauvin acted negligently and used
excessive force which led directly to
floyd's death
but the defense has been able to show
just by examining the prosecution's own
witnesses that the force he used
may not have been excessive in fact one
expert prosecution witness admitted on
the stand
that chauvin would have been justified
in using even more force he could have
used a taser on floyd for example
and would have been justified in doing
so you could argue that chauvin was
more restrained in his handling of floyd
than he needed to be you could argue
that
we've also seen and this again has come
out during questioning of prosecution
witnesses
that there was a hostile crowd at the
scene and this impacts the way officers
handle a suspect
we've seen that floyd was resisting was
belligerent was complaining that he
couldn't breathe
even before he was on the ground we've
seen that floyd had three times
three times the lethal dose of fentanyl
in his system
another prosecution witness testified
that floyd was foaming at the mouth
now once again this is a prosecution
witness supposed to be helping the
prosecution's case
saying that he saw floyd foaming at the
mouth
well is that more likely to be a sign of
someone overdosing or of them being
choked to death
yesterday the defense played a clip of
floyd apparently saying
i ate too many drugs now you could
hear that clip and argue that he didn't
say that that he might have said
something else
but i ate too many drugs is at least a
plausible interpretation of the clip you
don't have to strain very hard to say
well yeah it sounds like he said that
maybe he didn't but it sounds like he
did
that's all that matters is there a
plausible scenario where
chauvin is entirely innocent of causing
floyd's death
so far yes here's the scenario floyd
took three times the fatal
dose of a dangerous narcotic overdosed
and died
i mean that's the plausible scenario
it's consistent with the facts
there's evidence to support it and the
prosecution hasn't disproved it beyond a
reasonable doubt they haven't even begun
to disprove it
haven't gotten close to disproving it
there's more trial yet to be had but you
know there's enough
at this point enough reasonable doubt to
cover chauvin with some left over
in fact there's so much reasonable doubt
at this point that the real question is
why the case was even brought in the
first place a man with three times a
failed dose of a narcotic in his system
died while foaming at the mouth
speculation that chauvin may have still
been part of the cause but not the cause
or even the main cause
is not enough to convict a man of murder
in this country
or at least it shouldn't be
doesn't mean you have to believe chauvin
is innocent doesn't mean you have to
like him
doesn't mean you have to invite him over
for dinner it just means that reasonable
doubt is the standard and that standard
matters
our justice system is built on it we
don't have a justice system without it
we don't have justice without it
but then again the people shouting no
justice no peace
they don't care about justice do they
vengeance is what they're after
and they're determined to get it get
their vengeance
one way or another now let's get to our
five headlines
listen guys you know if there's one
thing that i know
uh or am an expert in it's uh fashion
you guys all know that people look to me
as a kind of a fashion guru or maybe
they don't maybe i need a lot of help
with fashion it depends on you know
your perspective may vary and that's why
i love vincero
watches you know they can make even
someone like me even a schlub like me
look look good vincero is loved by some
of your favorite entrepreneurs athletes
and
even podcast hosts like myself believe
me when i say i love my ventura project
products i have
i've got four or five of them now and i
wear them all the time these are hands
down the best products you can get for
the money when you pick
um one of their products you immediately
know you get what you paid for it's the
best value for your money
guaranteed these are really affordable
watches but not cheap watches and there
is a difference and it's all about the
quality right
right now is the perfect time to shop
vincero because right now is vancero's
spring
upgrade sale and they have what you need
to upgrade your style for the spring
take up to
30 off all of their brand new watches
and accessories and get ready to hit
this spring and summer feeling like a
new person
that this is one of their biggest sales
of the year and it's here for only a few
days
so you got to take advantage of this
deal now uh head over to v i
n c e r o collective dot com forward
slash walsh
no code is required your discount will
be automatically applied at checkout but
only if you access the sale by going to
vincerocollective.com
walsh everything on site is up to 30 off
no exclusions including sunglasses
wallets bracelets everything
go to my link and check out this awesome
sale going on at vincero
all right so the uh as mentioned the
police chief
in dc has explained
i was asked about um you know why the
teens in that case have not been charged
as an adult
and i thought his his answer was kind of
interesting
in the way that it may apply to the
other big murder case that we were just
talking about but let's listen to what
he had to say
this is a tragic case and you know
charging this person as an adult
and the juvenile uh you know would not
you know it's not
does not bring back the lost loved one
uh in this case the
youth involved are presented to court
and decisions are made
based upon district of columbia
guidelines and you know
as i stated previously i think the
question now is
are the guidelines that we have in place
specifically when you're talking about
carjacking
is it sufficient for our community uh
it's not gonna bring the loved one back
to put these girls in prison or charge
them as adults
well yeah that's true but are we going
to bring george floyd back by throwing
derrick chauvin
in jail so i mean
can you ever can you ever bring a loved
one back by by putting a murderer in
prison
that is always such a cop i hate when
people say that it's such a cop-out
in in in this kind of context well you
can't bring the person
of course you can't we all know that
yeah we also hear that a lot with
capital punishment people that are
anti-capital punishment they say you
know you're not going to bring the
person back by executing the killer
yes obviously but nothing that you do
with the killer is going to bring the
person back we know that so
by your logic what we should just do
nothing let them walk free all the time
not even have a prison because there's
absolutely nothing we can do with that
person that's gonna bring back their
victim
but if that's the way we're looking at
it then yeah there's all of this
stuff that we're doing with derek shove
and i you know the protest not not even
the merely the trial but the riots
rioting is that gonna bring back their
uh george floyd
no but you see in this case another
comparing and contrasting here
here's a good example of um when there's
no reasonable doubt
right there is no reasonable doubt
whatsoever about what killed muhammad
anwar how he died who killed him
these girls carjacked him um and then
drove off when he was hanging out of the
vehicle flipped it and he died they
killed him
no reasonable doubt about that
whatsoever nobody is
raising any questions about that we know
that that's what happened
the question is whether they should be
severely punished for it or just get a
um you know a kind of judicial slap on
the wrist and instead we're giving them
a slap on the wrist
until in into and waiting until that
moment 10 15 years from now or earlier
probably earlier uh when they inevitably
do something
that uh will will you know force the
system to put them away for longer
um number two so i you know
your mileage will vary on whether you
consider this to be news at all
but um i i think it's interesting and
this is my show
damn it so back off my case i did want
to i just want to mention this so i did
a um
i did a on my own poll it's not a
scientific poll not a scientific survey
but
by any means i realized that
but out of curiosity i put a poll up on
on my twitter page and i said as it
stands right now who would you prefer in
2024
and then the the only options here for
this for the purposes of this survey
desantis or trump right not a um
not a representative sample of the
electorate not a representative sample
of the
of the republican electorate okay even
so
in the course of a day there are about
75 000 votes that's a lot
and i i just found the results to be to
be really interesting um
desantis on this poll
got 70 percent verse 30 for trump
70 verse 30. now does again
not a scientific poll does that mean
that that desantis would win in a
primary against trump
probably no probably not i think trump
would still prob would still most likely
when we have a lot of time before we get
to the um
to the primaries a lot can happen in the
meantime
but even so
i have a feeling if i had done that poll
four months ago five months ago the
results would have been completely
flipped
now but you could you can look at this
you could look at this as a in a
positive or negative way
if the only thing you care about is
trump's political future
right if you're not so much a
conservative as just a trumpist and and
that's all
and he's the only guy he's the only guy
you want the only guy you care about the
only thing you care about politically is
trump
then you see something like this and you
you look at that a negative way
that's bad news for you but
um if you're a conservative
and you're the supporter of the maga
movement
then this is a positive because what it
would seem to indicate
is that you know trump supporters have
found
someone who they think can carry that
banner carry the mantle the mega mantle
and that's exactly what's needed one way
or another because even if trump runs
again in 2024 at the age of 78
which i've said along i hope he does not
do
i mean my posit leaving everything else
aside i've been very
clear i do not support 78 year olds
running for president i don't think i
don't think anyone should be doing that
at that age
i don't think anyone over over the age
of 75 should be running
and as i've said i think i think there
should be laws preventing that from
happening but there aren't
as far as i'm concerned anyway as a
voter i i can't support that you're
you're just too old and we're seeing now
um what happens when you hire when you
elect someone at that age so
but even if he runs again whatever
happens like in in the not too distant
future
there's going to have to be someone to
take that
banner and march forward trump is gonna
have to pass the baton on
sooner rather than later no matter what
because he is an old older man and he's
not gonna live forever
even if he won in 2024 he's out in 2028
for good and uh
the fact that that desantis is stepping
up to take that uh take that banner
that's a very positive
development you know
i i think desantis has a lot of trump's
upside
and lacks a lot of his downside he
doesn't have all the same
charisma he doesn't have all the same
celebrity factor he doesn't quite have
that
but he does have a lot of charisma he's
very good at dealing with the media
he's a he's a kind of you know tell like
it is sort of that that's his approach
um he's he's got a lot of governing
experience
he's interested in policy in a way that
trump
never was clearly i think he's got a lot
of the upside
not a lot of the same downside then he
has some extra upside that trump didn't
have
so i see this as a positive development
all right um moving on number three
here's the newsweek i'm just going to
give you the headline it says can blood
from young people
slow aging silicon valley has
bet billions at will biotech startups
are trying to hack the process of aging
and in the process
stave off the most devastating diseases
okay so
we start harvesting blood from young
people
to stop aging now there's a there's a
non-creepy way of
of looking at this so there's a
non-creepy way this could go
because if you're talking about for
example i don't know coming up with a
treatment for alzheimer's
and that involves you know some some
element of blood transfusion or blood
from
younger people and it's it's it's and
the reason that you're doing it is to
cure
a terrible disease well i don't think
anyone would object to that there's no i
don't see any real ethical dilemma as
long as you're not taking
all of the blood from a young person as
long as you're not killing them to
harvest their blood
do a 100 blood transfusion now
i think there we could agree that
there's some ethical problems maybe
assuming that's not the case then that
that's not an issue but
this overall effort um
not focused on one particular disease
but
this view of aging itself as aging
itself is a disease
we have to stop that process
and just extend human life indefinitely
that i think is where we take issue
and it's uh it's also there's um
speaking of double-edged swords because
it would seem that the people who are
most obsessed with this and most focused
on this we have to extend human life we
have to just keep extending and
extending your study as much as we can
treat aging itself as a disease aging is
a bad thing
to hang on to youth at any and all costs
the people who have that view are
probably more likely to be godless
faithless
and for them you know this physical life
is all we have
the if you when you die you simply cease
to exist
and you disappear evaporate into the
void it's a horrifying thought
and if that's your your outlook
then yeah you need to extend like
because that's all we got we just have
to extend human life
by any means necessary but then also
if that's your view life is meaningless
and there's something inherently
despairing about it
it's meaningless it's empty we're not
here for any purpose
and no matter what even if you extend
life from
you know even if we make it so that
people can live to 200
in the grand scheme of things that's a
blink of an eye
you can make it so that people live to
500
well compared to the to the age of the
universe that's nothing
might as well be a day
so you have to keep extending life
because there's nothing beyond it
but then also your belief that something
beyond it means that life is meaningless
and miserable and gray and dreary so
you're extending this meaningless
miserable thing
uh it's just kind of one way or another
there's no there's no good answer
i guess all right moving on this is from
reuters it says
um this is a story that sounds scary
until you think about it for two seconds
all right let me read from this it says
1 in 3 coven 19 survivors in a study of
more than 230 000 mostly american
patients
were diagnosed with a brain or
psychiatric disorder within six months
suggesting the pandemic could lead to a
wave of mental and neurological problems
according to scientists
now think about that one in three that's
pretty scary
but notice how it says brain or
psychiatric disorder
notice how those two things are lumped
together but those are two
very very different things so let's keep
reading it says researchers who
conducted the analysis said it was not
clear how the virus was linked to
psychiatric conditions such as anxiety
and depression
but these were the most common diagnoses
among the 14 disorders they looked at
post-covet cases of stroke dementia and
other neurological disorders were rarer
but were still significant paul harrison
a professor of psychiat
psychiatry at oxford university said
although the individual risks for for
most disorders are small the effect
across the whole population may be
substantial
um it says health experts are clearly
increasingly concerned by evidence of
higher risks of brain and mental health
disorders among cop19 survivors
previous study by the same researchers
found last year that twenty percent
of covenant survivors were diagnosed
with a psychiatric disorder within three
months
um and the new findings analyzed
health records and mostly the united
states about 34 have been diagnosed with
neurological or psychiatric illnesses
within
the month i'm trying to get to what
these desire okay here we go here fine
here are the disorders that we're
talking about
um it says anxiety at 17 percent
and mood disorders at 14 were the most
common
it did not appear to be related to how
mild or severe the patient's covenant
infection had been
among those have been admitted to
intensive care with severe covenant
however seven percent had a stroke
within six months and almost two percent
were diagnosed with dementia okay so it
sounds scary you keep reading you get to
the bottom
and um you find out that in the vast
majority of these cases
we we hear psychiatric or neurological
well
vast majority it's psychiatric not
neurological
now if you told me one in three of kova
19 survivors had a um
i don't like even like using the term
survivor here because it makes it sound
like covet 19 a much higher fatality
rate than it really did
but if you told me that one in three
people who had kova 19 had neurological
disorders
now that is something but
anxiety mood disorders depression
these are already very vague things
really hard to define
um whether they count
as a disorder or a sort of a
an inherent part of the human condition
is at a minimum something up that's up
for discussion
but even so you know during this whole
process when we've all been
under lockdowns and we
you know nothing but the fear-mongering
from the media and everything
can we think of other reasons why people
may be suffering from
depression and anxiety and mood
disorders
nikki can you think of other reasons why
over the last year there might have been
a spike in those things
whether you had coven 19 or not
and as far as two percent diagnosed with
dementia
um well we also have to keep in mind
that the vast majority of people
who had the worst symptoms were elderly
so you got to factor that in too all
right um
finally here's a good tick tock video
for this is a good one for a change
not not good so much in what it reveals
but uh
but at least it makes a good point so
there here's someone interviewing
uh white liberals about voter id laws
and let's just let's just listen to
these people and and the reasonings that
they give for their view let's let's
hear do you have an opinion on voter id
laws uh yeah they're
usually pretty racist i think voter id
laws are a way to perpetuate racism
would you go as far to say that
those laws are racist for sure do you
think it suppresses the
african-american vote definitely because
they're less likely to have
state ids these type of people don't
live in
areas with easy access to dmvs or other
places where they can get identification
do you think that's harder for black
people to go online
well i feel like they don't have the
knowledge of how of like how it works
do you carry id yes i do do you know
anybody who any black person doesn't
carry id
no do you have id yes because i have my
id and my friends have their id
so we know what we need to carry around
everybody that i know have id
like that's one of the things you need
to walk around with new york with
i heard a lot also that black people
can't figure out how to get to the dmv
really is that that was that senior i
know it's that one 25th year do you know
where the id
the dmv is right here it's on 125th
street in third avenue
these these type of people
don't know how to get uh don't know how
to get their ids
or they don't understand you know you
see these very concerned woke white
liberals
they're just concerned for these
minorities who don't don't understand
really basic things
that is some of the
most extreme racism i've i've seen
captured on film in quite some time
and every single one of those those uh
the white people in that video if you
ask them
they would identify themselves as
anti-racist not just
because it's not good enough remember to
be not racist you have to be anti-racist
and all of them i guarantee would say oh
yeah anti-racist
that is how that is how super not racist
i am i'm anti-racist
and at the same time i think that uh
black people as a group
can't figure out how to get an id or
they they these what was what was the
exact quote from that guy these type of
people
live and live in places where there
aren't dmvs what
um so i assume you mean cities
and uh there are no dmvs in a city what
there's a dmv every three blocks
i just i live very close to a city i
work in a city now here in nashville
and um i went to get my id yesterday
finally changed over
first time that i've moved to a new
state and gotten my id changed over
within
you know usually takes me about three
years to do it but this time i did it in
a few months so i felt good about that
but there are i was looking at the gps
there are about four or five different
dmvs right in the vicinity
and you walk in and they they make it
very very easy it is not complicated
i've been to
many dmvs in many states i've been
through this process many times
moving around and getting ids so i've
been through this a lot
i'm no genius myself i can figure this
out they make it so easy
you walk you you it's you couldn't
possibly do it wrong
they literally idiot proof it you walk
in you go to the desk
they give you they tell you everything
that you need you present the documents
they give you a little
ticket it's got your number printed real
big there they tell you go sit down over
there on those chairs
and when your number comes up it's going
to flash on a screen
and there's also going to be a voice
repeating it over and over and over
again
d46 it's your turn at the window d46 d46
d46
you couldn't possibly do it wrong
and that's why almost every adult you
come across
black white or otherwise has an id
it is not hard at all to do
um and by the way the i will say
the nashville dmv is i think sort of the
it's like the chick-fil-a of dmvs
friendly quick efficient i have never
had such a pleasant dmv experience
so i would recommend that to you move to
nashville just for the dmv experience if
nothing else
you know i've been telling you about my
friends over at
because we know the constitution is
constantly under attack in this country
and we as conservatives have to you know
be
be ready to defend it uh intellectually
first of all and that means
understanding the constitution
we also have to be ready to defend
ourselves physically my friends over
constitutioncoach.com have a lot of
great programs for all of this for
equipping citizens to defend liberty by
studying and living out the constitution
i've experienced their constitutional
defense course myself
can't recommend it highly enough you can
get an amazing combination of
intellectual ammunition
and also you get physical training at
the premier firearms facility in the
nation
all in the same course you get to join
hundreds of other patriots from across
the nation for a time of learning
training and fellowship with like-minded
people doesn't matter where you are
you know where your skills are whether
you've shotguns your whole life or if
you've never touched one
these people they took me to an entirely
new skill level and they could do the
same for you they could do it for anyone
don't just get a gun learn how to carry
with confidence and get the training you
need to defend your family go to
constitutioncoach.com
rick and the constitution coach team
have another class on april 25th but
uh you're coming up on on your final
chance to sign up it's filling up very
quickly so you got to go to
constitutioncoach.com today
watch my video there to see more about
the training but then make sure you get
signed up
at constitutioncoach.com all right let's
move on to reading the youtube comments
uh big mac says mr gorbachev tear off
these balls arguably the greatest line
of the matte wall show well thank you
for that and uh i do believe
th that that line probably is my
not just the greatest line of show i
think it's my greatest professional
achievement
i don't think i'll ever top it and that
says more about my professional
achievements than it does about the line
but even so
mark says surely you can't be serious
about quota systems and flying
i am serious and don't call me shirley
do movie quotes get you canceled
well usually mark they would but um this
one
yeah someone had to throw in the
airplane quote given the subject so i'll
let that one slide
tony tran says me aliens do not exist
people how do you know when you've never
seen one me how do you know they exist
when you've never seen one well tony i
think that this
was what we'll call straw man most
people don't say that they know aliens
exist
it's just that there's a i would say
that there's a
very high probability of it
and that's got really nothing to do with
all the ufo videos now
even if we had never seen a single ufo
video i would still say
very high probability of some kind of
other life form out there in the
universe
simply given the fact that there are
billions and billions of galaxies and
with with billions of solar systems and
trillions of planets
um what's the mathematical likelihood
that we are
of all the trillions and trillions and
trillions and trillions of planets
across the universe we are the only one
where life has ever developed any kind
of life
that's the argument um bleem says
matt how much do you bench all the gym
bros want to know
uh you know i usually put up like 450
reppin
no big deal 450 500.
if you ever see me at the gym you won't
i don't
i don't often actually bench that cause
i don't want to make people feel bad
when they're there you know i find it's
bad for people's self-esteem so if you
ever saw me at the gym you i probably
wouldn't be benching to 450.
that's only just out of my own humility
just so you know um
texas sellers finally says matt i know
you're a father so i want your advice on
this
when the baby's been fed been played
with not tired but still cranky
what else is there to do other than put
them in their prison cell
and drink your beer well it depends on
how old so
you you say baby i'm thinking you mean
you know like infant age because at
infancy you don't need the
the prison cell slash what they used to
call it a playpen
you don't really need that you just you
lay them down and they that's the great
thing about babies
they can be difficult but the great
thing about a baby
is that they don't move and you should
really cherish that when you have it
so you can put them down doesn't mean
you put them in a room on the floor and
you leave for
five hours but you can put them down and
you know and they'll stay there
so that's good if you know you've met
all of the baby's needs um
then yeah there does reach a point where
you put the child down
and you know take a breather
you have to be able to do that now i i
am
hesitant about wading into this to these
waters especially because i know there
are a lot of women who watch the show a
lot of mothers
the uh the cry it out method as it's
called
highly controversial and i know that i'm
gonna make people very angry
by by wading into those waters but i am
a proponent of that method personally
sometimes you have to put the baby down
in a crib or something you know all the
needs have been met
like you said you fed changed all that
still crying you put the baby down you
let them cry out no it doesn't mean you
leave them for three hours but
20 minutes or something let them get get
past it
i think for your own sanity sometimes
you have to be able to do that
now a quick word from relief band you
know relief bend is all about
dealing with nausea and anyone who
struggles with nausea you know it's it's
not fun to put it mildly
uh for me it's car sickness and i spend
a lot of time in the back of
of cars when i'm traveling uber or
whatever going to and from airports
hotels and all that kind of stuff
and uh so i i have that that that nausea
or at least i did have that car sickness
problem and still i start until i
started using relief band relief band is
the number one fda cleared anti-nausea
wristband that's been clinically proven
to quickly relieve and effectively
prevent nausea and vomiting
which is associated with motion sickness
anxiety migraine hangover morning
sickness chemotherapy and so much more
the product is 100 drug free it's
non-drowsy so it's a lot better than you
know any of those pills you could take
that's gonna
make you sleepy for the rest of the day
and it's got zero side effects
technology was originally developed over
20 years ago in hospitals to
relieve nausea from patients but now
through relief band it's available to
the masses and you got to take advantage
of this
this year ensure that nausea this year
is never the reason to miss out on
life's important moments right now
relief band has an exclusive
offer just for matt walsh listeners if
you go to reliefband.com and use promo
code walsh you'll receive 20 percent off
plus free shipping and no questions
asked
30 day money back return policy uh so
head to reliefbent r-e-l-i-e-f-b-a-n-d
dot com and use our promo code walsh for
20 off
now as we return from eastern passover
you know we're reflecting on
the impact these holidays have on our
faith and on our values in general
and we know that the left wants to erase
these values and replace them with
their own pseudomorality and that's why
we've launched a brand new talk show
with candace owens
a fierce protector of conservative
values and free speech one of the best
out there so you can go behind the
headlines and the twitter arguments to
see candace as herself
candice is also available um uh is
the first daily wire show that we're
doing in front of a live studio audience
and you can watch it if you go to
dailywire.com you can sign up with code
candace but you can also get the podcast
as well the audio podcast candice
is available on apple spotify or
wherever you listen to your podcast
so if you need some candice owens in
your podcast feed look no further head
over to apple podcast or spotify and
subscribe today
and be sure to leave a five star review
if you like what you hear
now let's get to our daily cancellation
today we're gonna cancel a lady on the
view whose name apparently is sarah
though i don't know her last name and i
don't feel like looking it up she earned
herself applause and lots of you go
girls yesterday during a debate over
vaccine
passports sarah came out in favor of the
passports
and here is her reasoning let's listen i
i cannot argue
privacy on a public health issue like
this when i don't understand how the
most
private thing in my body my uterus seems
to be open for business when it's
convenient politically
so i will say that these passports are a
great idea
uterus open for business well
we don't need to know about that that's
your own concern um now planned
parenthood by the way of course tweeted
that clip out loved it
as i said lots of feminists expressed
their appreciation of her point there
i can't quite join them in their round
of applause though mostly because
that was extremely dumb and let's just
let's let's count the ways first of all
what exactly are you saying here sarah
that that you
you think you don't have privacy with
respect to abortion
so therefore nobody should have it with
respect to vaccinations
if i can't have privacy then nobody can
is that your position
i'll do you a favor and assume that that
wasn't your point
even though that was literally the point
you that you were making i'll assume
that you were in a clumsy way just
attempting to note what you perceive to
be
a contradiction you see it as
hypocritical or ironic that people who
oppose abortion
would also oppose vaccine passports
but the problem is that the hypocrisy
and irony actually runs entirely the
other way
see there's nothing contradictory about
someone arguing that
we shouldn't be forced to get vaccines
and also that we shouldn't be allowed to
kill our children
those two positions are in no way
whatsoever at odds with each other
i can advocate for privacy when it comes
to vaccines yet still say that you
shouldn't be granted the privacy to kill
your baby
you see i like i can take i can believe
both of those things and i do
there's nothing logically unsound about
arguing that privacy should extend as
far as vaccines
but not as far as killing babies
meanwhile
you're professing a belief in privacy
rights that is so absolute
so radical that it even permits you to
kill your own child
but you don't think we should have the
privacy to decide what vaccines we take
you go from a privacy rights absolutist
to an anti-privacy absolutist
you go from bodily autonomy extremism
to chucking bodily autonomy out the
window completely
you say that you have the privacy rights
and autonomy to kill a person
but not to decide what vaccines you put
in your body
you have taken the extremist position on
both
sides of these issues you have done that
what's happening here is something very
similar to what happens with the capital
punishment debate
right people who are anti-capital
punishment and
pro-abortion will point at the
pro-capital punishment and anti-abortion
side and accuse
us of having a self-contradictory view
if we say we're pro-life then how can we
possibly support the execution of
criminals
but of course there's nothing remotely
contradictory or arbitrary about the
view that killing innocent and
defenseless children is wrong
yet executing convicted adult murderers
is right
one can believe it justified to execute
a man who say raped and killed a child
without also believing that it's
justified to crush an infant's skull in
the womb
those two positions are not at odds with
each other in fact they line up quite
logically and sensibly
we are so opposed to the murder of of
innocent people
that we think the people who commit
those crimes may in some cases be
eligible for the harshest punishment
see it's our for for those and not every
pro-life person is in favor of the death
penalty by the way many are not
but as someone who who is i will say
it is partially my conviction
my belief in the value of human life
that causes me to be in favor of the
death penalty
because i consider it to be such a
heinous act
to kill an innocent person
that the harshest available punishment
should be applied to you you may not
agree with this point of view but to
pretend that it's incoherent is silly
it's it's a perfectly coherent point of
view
i'll tell you what is incoherent it is
incoherent to say
that a child-killing rapist or
a serial killer has a right to live but
a baby
doesn't have a right to live it's
incoherent to treat the execution of a
convicted murderer some great injustice
and yet to celebrate the execution of
infants
once again the contradiction the moral
insanity is all on the other side
even though i'm used to it i still can't
help but be almost shocked at the
gumption
of the pro-abortion side that they would
accuse us of being moral hypocrites
when they're the ones who support
executions only for the youngest and
most defenseless among us
that position is simply not not
defensible itself
second point for our friend sarah just
at sort of a technical point
sarah claims as all proborts do that uh
pro-lifers are somehow trying to control
her uterus
well let me allay those concerns sarah
and tell you that we don't care about
your uterus
we're not the ones talking about it you
guys are the ones who are constantly
talking about your uterus is and other
assorted body parts
you're the one always bringing it up and
it's really weird i gotta say it's very
weird for us
because that's not what we're trying to
talk about like we're talking about
abortion and then you weirdos come
running in what are you doing talking
about my body and my uterus we're not
calm down that's not the conversation
we're looking to have
our point is not about your body it's
not about you actually if you can
believe it you're narcissist
it's about the body of your child and
the only point we're making about the
body of your child is that one
your child's body is not your body
they're two separate distinct entities
and two
you shouldn't have the right to destroy
your child's body
that's it that's all we're saying yes
your child's body is dependent upon your
body but that doesn't make his body the
same as
your body and it doesn't make it okay to
kill him
just because somebody is dependent upon
you that doesn't mean that you should be
able to kill that person if it did
that would mean that parents would have
the right to kill their children way
beyond the womb
infants babies toddlers adolescents even
some grown adults
are dependent on their parents for
survival a newborn baby
speaking of newborns is nearly as
dependent on his mother's body
out of the womb as he was inside it
do you think that that gives you the
right to bash your newborn skull
you know against the rock and throw them
in a dumpster
i would hope not most of us recognize
that parents have a responsibility to
their born children
we compel them right we compel them by
law by force
to care for their children we say to
parents
you have to you don't have a choice you
have to care for your children
if you can't or you don't want to you
have to find someone who will you have
to make other arrangements
may not be difficult to do you know you
put them up for adoption some states
make it easier than others
for parents to um offload their kids
and find someone else to to care for
them but whatever the process there's
gonna be there's a process in place
right and you have to follow it
if you don't you'll go to prison what
you can't do is just leave your kid on
the side of the road
least of all can you simply kill your
child
right the point of pro-lifers is that
this principle the principle that you
are responsible to
and for your child and don't have the
right to intentionally harm your child
should apply in the womb just as much as
it does outside of it that's a
consistent view that is a rationally
defensible view
that's a morally salient view which is
more than i can say about your position
a position that is as logically
incoherent as it is morally deranged
a position that today has earned you the
title of
cancelled and that'll do it for us today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vadasky
the show is edited by sasha tolmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair makeup is done by nika geneva and
our production coordinator is mckenna
waters
the matte wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire
2021 united airlines promises
affirmative action for pilots
rich liberals turn alex jones rants into
reality
and aoc babbles even less coherently
than usual check it out on the michael
knowles show
[Music]